Over the past two
years, we've been
working on this
workflow that's been
helpful for us in processing
large amounts of data
very quickly in order to
create products that help guide
the decision making in the state
of where to allocate resources.
This workflow involves three
main products Microsoft Azure
DevOps, RStudio
Workbench, and RStudio Connect.
If you're at the
keynote this morning,
you'll realize
some of these terms
are a little outdated, since
we're now changing to Posit.
When I first started working
at CDP, it was December 2020.
I was living in Washington,
DC in Foggy Bottom,
so not too far from here.
And if you remember,
in our personal lives,
it was quite stressful.
So going outside was kind
of like rolling the dice
on whether you might get
sick or get other sick.
And you can imagine working
in public health is also
quite stressful.
Our infrastructure wasn't
prepared for the amount of data
that COVID was going to
provide, and we're often trying
to catch up and get ahead.
I happened to be
working on a report
at that time that got sent
out at the end of the day.
And I would get
this beautiful data
set that was processed
by many colleagues
from the local
health jurisdictions
and at the state level.
And sometimes there would
be delays to no fault
that anyone the situation
is very complicated,
data was always
changing. So this often
meant 9:00 pm, 10 p.m., 11:00
pm, California time, midnight,
1:00 AM 2:00 AM in DC.
So I have to look like this.
I was very tired and my cat was
wondering why I'm still awake.
As a team,
we knew this wasn't
feasible and we
needed to do something
to change this,
not only to meet the
needs of the state,
but also to improve
our work life balance.
So eventually this workflow
came about allowing
us to do our work
more efficiently,
and I got into bed at
a more reasonable time.
So reducing our stress and
required four main things.
The first one is how
we prioritize our task.
How do we improve our ability
to collaborate with each other?
How do we decrease
our turnaround time?
And then lastly, how
do we scale our work?
So I'm going to
start with how do we
improve our prioritization?
So during this time there were
many requests was coming in
and there's often the undertone
of I needed this yesterday.
And that's very true because
the questions and issues
that were having impacted the
health of millions of people.
And the issue, however, is that
as a team we're quite limited.
There's only so many of us.
Our skills vary and we want to
be able to solve these issues,
but we only have so
much time as well.
So we needed a way
to prioritize how
we move forward in our work.
So that's where the
first product comes in,
Microsoft Azure DevOps, and
we use Microsoft Azure DevOps
at CDP because we're
a Microsoft shop.
But you could use
other DevOps platforms as well
in place of this.
So we started using Azure
DevOps for project management,
in particular a sprint board.
And a sprint is a
defined period of time
that you set to complete
a number of tasks.
And what's really
great about a sprint is
that at the very
beginning of the sprint,
it forces you to sit down and
decide what needs to be done,
what can realistically be
done in this time period,
and who's going to do it.
And for us, we happen to
use a two week sprint time,
but you could use different
amount of time as well.
So what I'm going to
do next is show you
what our sprint
board looks like,
to give you a sense of that.
So we have five
columns features, not
started, declined,
in progress, and done.
In the feature
column, you're going
to have an overarching project.
So, for example, preparing
for this RStudio conference talk,
and within that, you're going
to have a number of tasks
to complete within your sprint.
So in the not
started, I might have
tasks about drafting slides or
practicing this presentation.
And you can be the judge
of whether I successfully
did these or not.
I may have declined columns
such as adding cat GIFs
and at some point
realized or decided
this wasn't a professional
enough thing to add.
So I'm not going to do that.
I'll have an in-progress column
such as drafting outline, which
I need to do prior
to doing the slides
or practicing my presentation.
And then lastly, I'll finish
a couple of tasks too.
So such as making
this sprint board example,
which again, you can judge
of whether I successfully
did that or not.
And then we'll have other
rows with other features
for separate tasks.
And this provides a
really great visualization
for our team of how we're
doing in this sprint.
And what's really powerful
is that as sprints continue
to occur, we can
look back in time
and see how successful we
were at completing our task
and modify how we're
going to move forward
in the next sprint.
And if you're disappointed
that I didn't add any gifts,
I added some last
minute for you.
So next, how did we
improve our collaboration?
So when I first started, we were
using Git and DevOps principles
in some places, but it wasn't
a main part of our workflow.
So a lot of our work was shared
across a shared drive or folder
in at work, and that often
meant copying your R script,
for example, and
then making edits
and later putting
it back together,
which over time was starting
to make a lot of problems
especially when it came down to
production, or it was late at night
at midnight and edits
were just very frustrating
and tiring to do.
And so we started to use Git
principle, or Git workflow
more effectively and made it
a main part of our workflow.
So if you think about our
work and RStudio Workbench,
it's kind of like
we're in a silo.
It's really hard
to share this work
with others or the
colleagues, and we
wanted to be able to do that.
So that's where we started using
repositories via Azure DevOps.
And a repository
is a place, a place
where you can store your code
safely, have version control,
and it's this central place
that all of your work can live.
And what's great about
this is that via RStudio
and Git, we can move our work
outside of our silo
into this repository.
And in that same vein, I
can move other people's work
from the repositories into my
Workbench and work on it there.
Now you can have an
entire workshop about Git
and still may not understand it.
It's very confusing, but
there's a really great resource
by Jenny Bryan
called Happy Git
that's related to using Git in R
that we encourage you to check
out if you want to
get started with Git and R.
So you can think of
repositories as if you're
storing your code safely.
So in these photos
by Eadweard Muybridge,
we're seeing this
the spirit in flight
and we're getting snapshots,
shots, snapshots of it
over time.
And you can think of
our code every time
we make a commit
or a save, we're
saving a version of it in
memory, in the repository.
So maybe you want to put this
last snapshot into production,
but something goes wrong.
What's great about repository is
that we can roll back the clock
and use this previous
version to go
into production and
in the meantime,
fix our errors that
occurred later on.
And another really
great feature is
that you can make
what's called a fork
or a branch of a repository,
and that's like making a copy of it.
And you can kind of
think of it as if you're
working in your own land.
In that sense, we're all
running in the sprint
and I have my own
fork or branch and I'm
working at making edits.
And if I happen
to make a mistake,
it's not going to affect
others in their lane.
So it gives us a really
great opportunity
to try new things out,
fall over, break the app,
all of those things
that we don't want
to happen during production.
And lastly, how to
improve or turnaround
time and scalability?
So we're always getting
requests and lots of data
that we're taking ownership of,
and these data processing can
take hours.
And that same time, we also want
to be able to scale our work
and share it with others.
So that's where
our final product
comes in, RStudio Connect.
And this is a server that allows
you to automate your processes.
And what's really cool is
that from our repositories
in Azure DevOps,
we can deploy our work
into RStudio Connect.
And from Connect, we can
automate data processing.
We can schedule reports.
And we can post Shiny apps.
So RStudio Connect provided
us more processing power,
which allowed us to do
analyses more quickly.
So just as an example,
this is one of our servers.
We have about 251 gigabytes
of ram, which is a lot.
Or another example, the
amount of CPU cores available.
And we have a number of
these servers available to us
to do different types of
data processing or host apps.
And I can't explain
the giddiness
I felt the first time I ran
a script on Connect that
took 10 minutes when it
used to take over an hour
to run if it didn't crash.
So Connect was a
really great lifesaver
in terms of finishing our
data processing in more
quickly, quick manner allowing
me to go to sleep earlier.
So it's not only quicker, but
it also freed up our hands.
At least in our
environment, we're
limited to two workbenches.
So that's kind of like having
two R consoles or two tabs.
And if I have many
types of data that I
need to process
throughout the week,
it's as if my hands are tied.
So BY being able to offload
it off to a server,
I can free up my hands to
do other type of work.
And we can schedule
jobs on the server.
I'm using, for example, the
officer or openxls package
to make PowerPoints Excel
sheets or Word documents.
And in that same
data processing,
we can also be doing the
data, the large amount of data
processing and then
creating reports that
are output at a scheduled time.
And we can schedule emails
with the blastula package
and a couple of emails here
and there is not too bad.
But when we start to
initiate emails and data
with a lot of
different partners,
this becomes a really
great tool to use.
And here's one example
of data that we
put on the website weekly for
post vaccination infection data
if you want to check it out.
And all of this data is
processed via Connect
and then shared
with our partners
at CDP to later
publish on the website.
So you can kind of
think of Connect
as if they're replacing us.
They're robots, they're
running in their own lane
and they're running
their own processes.
And so at this
point, I might want
to sit back and look at
my cat and listen to her
and stop looking
at this monitor.
But in reality, automation
isn't perfect and often
actually fails and can be
quite challenging to debug.
Working on a server,
the debugging process
is a lot different.
The logs are different.
So we try to.
So we need to think
about that as well.
So in reality,
it's more like this.
We're all running
in the same lane.
Some of the processes are
falling over, I'm falling over,
et cetera.
And one of the solutions to this
was to create a data processing
monitoring app.
So this monitors all
the processes on Connect
and it gives us a really
great visualization
of what's occurring.
And when it might fail.
And in addition to that, we
have an error logging system
where if something breaks, we
get an email via blastula telling us
something's broken and where
in that script it broke.
So I don't have time to share
that with you right now.
But if you're
interested, there's
actually a talk by my
colleagues, Kolbi Parrish,
and Andy Pham coming up next
that you could check out
to see that specific
piece of our workflow.
And then lastly, we have
many different Shiny apps,
mostly internal that I
can't share with you,
but one that was published to
the public by the California
COVID-19 modeling
team called calcat.
And this shows you
the current state
and predicted future state using
different models of COVID 19
in the State of California.
So I encourage you
to check this out
and see the different types of
data that we're working with.
And what's, I think, really cool is
that you can download the data
as well that we've
all been processing
and it's updated regularly.
So this gives you a
very high level overview
of the different tools that we
use to create this workflow.
Using Azure DevOps, RStudio
Workbench, and RStudio
Connect, allowing
us to process data
in a very quick amount of time.
And freeing up our hands
to make products that
help guide decision
making in the state
of where to allocate resources.
Thank you all for your time
and special thanks to the data
processing and informatics
section for all our hard work.